منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل انفجرت الاوضاع
داخل السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مناطق جغرافيه متباعده في هذا البلد
الشاسع شمالا مشاهدينا في المروي في الوسط
في الخرطوم وفي الغرب في دارفورت الان في
الاسبوع الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات يبدو
بان نقاط ونطاق هذه المواجهه الحاميه بين
الطرفين اصبحت اكثر تركيزا داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم اذا هذه العاصمه التي يقال عنها
مثلثه لماذا لانها تتكون من ثلاث تجمعات
سكانيه كما نتابع هنا الخرطوم بحري ام
درمان والخرطوم مدينه الخرطوم جنوبا يمكن
لنا ان نقول ان معظم الاشتباكات الدائره
الان في مدينه الخرطوم الجنوبيه تنحصر حول
نقطتين اساسيتين كما نشاهد هنا قياده
الولاده العامه للجيش السوداني والمطار
حول المطار هنا يقول الجيش السوداني بان
قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر على المطر اما
قياده الجيش القياده العامه فيسعى الطرفان
الان للسيطره عليها لماذا لان هذه النقطه
تعتبر استراتيجيه بمسار هذا النزاع الدائر
بين الطرفين اذا تنحصر المواجهه حول
المطار وحول القياده العامه حيث توجد
اشتباكات حاميه بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع في الخارج اما النقطه الثالثه
للاشتباكات فهي طبعا شرق المطار تقع
اشتباكات في حي الرياض كما نشاهد هنا كما
تقع اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه القصر
الجمهوري غربي المطار واشتباكات اخرى في
حي الصحافه وفي حي جبره وفي الكلا جنوب
غرب المطار اذا هذه خارطه الاشتباكات بهذه
النقطه اما مشاهدينا في ام درمان في ام
درمان غربي النيل توجد اشتباكات متفرقه
بين الطرفين اذا
تحديدا الاشتباكات تنحصر هنا حول مقر
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد هنا بهذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين هنا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول بانها تسيطر على هذه
النقطه وتسيطر على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بينما يسيطر الجيش على محتوى
البث عبر محطه خارجيه اما النقطه الخامسه
فهي في الخرطوم بحري الوضع هنا هادئ قليلا
واهدئ طبعا من الخرطوم لكنه يبقى محتدما
وقبل يومين كما تبعنا خرج سجناء من هذه
النقطه تحديدا
هي سجن كوبر والذي يعتبر من اشهر السجون
واكبر السجون في الخرطوم بحري بعدما قالت
الشرطه انها اضطرت لفعل ذلك بسبب انقطاع
خدمات المياه والكهرباء التي طبعا انقطعت
منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني اذا مشاهدينا
كانت هذه ابرز نقاط المواجهه بين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني التي كما قلنا
انها تنحصر الان في داخل العاصمه بمحيط
القياده العامه القصر الجمهوري ونقاط اخرى
كما فصلها لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات